bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat poursivre dans un
instant les discussions des sénateurs
autour du projet de loi relatif à la
modernisation de notre système de santé
un texte porté par la ministre des
Affaires sociales et de la santé Marisol
Touren texte débattu au Sénat depuis le
début de la semaine tout à l'heure aux
alentours de 13h une fois n'est pas
coutume le Sénat a adopté une mesure
fortement débattue et voulue par le
gouvernement il a adopté à titre
expérimental la mise en place de
salallle de consommation à moindre
risque de drogue il s'agit des fameuses
salles de shoot vous allez le voir le
débat était tendu le vote a été serré
certaines voix se sont élevées euh
argant des risques de sécurité des
risques pour le voisinage mais il y a
aussi eu les voix de certains sénateurs
de droite notamment les deux
corrapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales alain Milon Catherine
de roche également tous les deux
médecins qui ont plaidé en faveur de la
mise en place à titre expérimental de
ces salles
regardez drogués vont dans ces hôpitaux
rencontrent les
addictologues mes chers collègues qu'il
y en ait un par hôpital qui soit sauvé
de la drogue rien qu'un par hôpital qui
soit sauvé de la drogue sur l'ensemble
du territoire national si on en sauve 10
bah vous aurez fait une action
humanitaire extrêmement importante qui
est largement qui justifie largement le
fait de pouvoir le faire si vous ne le
faites pas vous les laissez dans les
rues vous les laissez continuer de se
droguer dans des avec un régime
sanitaire absolument néfaste et vous
n'en sauvez aucun moi je pense que notre
action en matière de santé c'est de
faire en sorte que les spécialistes de
la dictologie puisse entrer en contact
avec ces ces ces drogués et que ces
spécialistes puissent avec les
psychiatres faire en sorte qu'il puisse
sortir de là alors permettez
l'expérimentation puisqu'il s'agit
simplement d'une expérimentation
permettez que dans 6 mois on fasse le
bilan de cette expérimentation et puis
après on verra vous serez à nouveau
reconsulter si ça a été un échec
monstrueux si en effet dans ces salles
de shoot sont arrivés des dizaines de
millions de droguis du territoire
national ce qui à mon avis n'est pas le
cas à la rigueur on reviendra sur le
sujet mais moi je suis intimement
persuadé que dans 6 mois une fois qu'on
aura fait l'expérimentation on se rendra
compte que pas tous loin de là parce que
beaucoup aussi auront peur du contrôle
médical auront peur du contrôle policier
auront peur de donner leur leur identité
auront peur des tas de choses mais si
certains seront allés dans ces centres
se seront fait soigner ou auront
rencontré des médecins et que certains
progressivement essaieront de sortir de
la drogue ce sera un succès si par
contre Ben personne ne sort et que ça a
été la chienie complète ben ce sera un
échec la
ministre le constatera nous constaterons
et nous arrêterons mais permettez au
moins que qu'on fasse cet essai qui à
mon avis sera un succès merci monsieur
le Président donc je vais donner la
parole à ceux qui souhaitent faire des
explications de vote et je donne oui
attendez attendez s'il vous plaît madame
la ministre vous avez la
parole alors oui oui oui mais merci
madame la Présidente mesames messieurs
les les sénateurs je crois qu'il est
important de resituer la place que nous
entendons donner à cette expérimentation
puisqu'il s'agit bien d'une
expérimentation de salle de consommation
supervisé ou
réduite il y a dans notre pays des
personnes qui se droguent et nous avons
misise en place nous en avons évoqué
certaines auparavant nous avons mis en
place des politiques de réduction des
risques ces politiques elles se
diversifie ce que nous constatons et de
façon globale budgétairement nous
accompagnons ces politiques de
prévention avec des engagements
financiers tout à fait significatifs 600
millions d'euros environ entre la
sécurité sociale et l'État pour mettre
en place des politiques de prévention et
d'accompagnement ce que nous constatons
dans notre pays comme d'autres pays
l'ont constaté avant nous c'est qu'il y
a des usagers de drogue qui sont
totalement marginalisés et échappent si
j'ose dire à toutes les politiques qui
ont été mis en place et qui sont mis en
place ce sont souvent pas toujours
souvent des personnes qui qui vivent
dans la rue ce sont des personnes en
situation d'extrême précarité sociale
d'extrême précarité sanitaire et qui se
livre à des injections de drogue dans
des lieux publ de jour comme de nuit
dans des parcs publics dans les
escaliers de gare au vu et au su de tout
le monde il y a donc un enjeu de
sécurité sanitaire pour ces personnes il
y a un enjeu
d'ordre public pour l'ensemble de la
communauté principalement urbaine
puisque c'est dans les villes évidemment
que ces concentration ont lieu il y a
des expérimentations qui ont des des
plus que des expérimentations maintenant
des politiques qui ont lieu dans des
villes européennes ou des villes du
monde depuis plusieurs décennies 39
villes européennes d'ors et déjà ont mis
en place des salles de consommation à
moindre risque et les résultats sont au
rendez-vous nous ce que nous proposons
c'est d'expérimenter dans des villes qui
sont candidates entre guillemets pour le
faire qui souhaite le faire il ne s'agit
pas d'imposer à qui que ce soit la mise
en place de ces salles de consommation à
moindre risque et il y a deux villes qui
publiquement je ne dis rien des autres
il y a deux villes qui publiquement se
sont portées candidates Paris et
Marseille et je ne dis rien des autres
par parce que il y a des réflexions qui
se sont engagées dans des villes de
couleur politique d'ailleurs tout à fait
différentes et variées si je prends le
cas de l'Espagne par
exemple mais on retrouve la même chose
dans tous les pays quels sont les les
résultats le premier résultat c'est
d'aboutir à une diminution significative
des décès par overdose ce qui est quand
même un enjeu sanitaire tout à fait
important
en Espagne par exemple on est passé de
1830 décès en 1991 par overdose à 770 en
2008 on a des résultats dans des
proportions à peu près équivalentes pour
la Norvège ou les Pays-Bas d'autre part
nous constatons dans l'ensemble de ces
pays que la mise en place de ces salles
s'est accompagnée d'une réduction très
forte à peu près de moitié même parfois
un peu plus du taux de nouvelles
infection par le VIH euh puisque il y a
un encadrement et un accompagnement euh
sanitaire il y a même des pays dans
lesquels euh il y a une suppression
totale c'est le cas du
euh c'est le cas des Pays-Bas où il n'y
a eu euh plus aucun cas euh de
contamination par le VIH chez les
usagers de drogue nous constatons par
ailleurs dans ces pays euh qu'il y a une
réduction très forte de la quantité de
déchets liés aux injections laiss dans
les lieux publics puisque en France on
retrouve
régulièrement des seringues usagées ou
notamment dans des bacs à sable dans les
escaliers des gardes donc je veux
indiquer que cette expérimentation
elle n'est pas destiné à un public large
de d'usagers de drogue ceux-là sont pris
en charge plus ou moins bien plus ou
avec des résultats plus ou moins
positifs selon les individus mais ils
sont prise en charge par des structures
des carrudes des des lieux
d'accompagnement social et sanitaire
nous ciblons une population qui
aujourd'hui échappe à toutes les
politiques qui ont été mises en place et
qui donc se retrouvent livré à elle-même
laissé à elle-même
abandonné sans accompagnement social
sans accompagnement sanitaire sans
accompagnement psychologique et le
président Milon le disait si nous avons
la possibilité de sauver une personne
par centre mais c'est bien plus que cela
euh nous ne savons pas si toutes les
personnes accompagnées enfin nous savons
que toutes les personnes accompagnées
n'échapperont pas à la drogue ne nous
faisons pas d'illusion mais nous savons
que nous avons les moyens de réduire
très significativement très
significativement les décès directement
liés à la consommation de drogue et cela
c'est un enjeu ma un enjeu majeur ça
seat en centaines de cas en centaines
d'overdoses qui pourront être évités ça
seat en prise en charge sanitaire
supplémentaire pour un coût et je
termine par là qui est limité vous
n'avez pas porter cela mais je veux le
dire j'aivoqué 600 millions d'euros pour
les politiques de prévention des risques
une salle de consommation à moindre
risque le coût en est évalué à environ
800000 € par an donc on voit bien que on
n'est pas du tout dans les mêmes
catégories et nous avons prévu 3 million
et demi pour ces expérimentations
puisque que nous comptons sur quelques
expérimentations dans les premières dans
les premières années d'ailleurs avant
l'évaluation il n'y aura pas plus que
quelques expérimentations sur le sol de
notre pays donc j'appelle vraiment à un
vote comment dire à un vote de
responsabilité sanitaire de
bienveillance aussi d'attention envers
des personnes qui sont très souvent
totalement perdu totalement abandonné et
il est de notre responsabilité
collective de ne pas les laisser et de
leur proposer des solutions
thérapeutiques merci madame la ministre
nous allons passer aux explications de
vote monsieur dodigni a la parole pour 2
minutes et
demi merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues je fais
men bien entendu tous les arguments qui
viennent d'être présent présenté par
monsieur le rapporteur d'abord et
ensuite par Madame la Ministre et je
voulais moi aussi rappeler que ce sujet
avait été traité en 2010 par une
précédente ministre de la Santé madame
Roseline bachot qui proposait de la même
façon elle-même d'expérimenter des
salles de consommation de drogue elle
avait été à l'époque désavoué par le
Premier ministre monsieur François filon
avec une prime qui avait été donc donnée
aux aspects moraux et à ologie sur la
raison scientifique je pourrais dire que
ce sont les mêmes choix politiques qui
un temps ont fait interdire la publicité
pour le préservatif parce que ça être
l'incitation la débauche sont les mêmes
choix politiques qui ont dénoncé à un
moment les programmes d'échange de
seringue c'est pourquoi je veux de façon
solennelle particulièrement saluer la
position de notre commission des
affaires sociales qui je la cite a
mesurer l'intérêt qui attach à
l'expérimentation des salles de
consommation à moindre risque après les
auditions et les échanges menés avec les
professionnels d' dictologie je veux
saluer de la même façon madame la
ministre votre détermination votre
lucidité vous qui prenez le risque on se
rend compte que cette proposition
devienne la cible facile de commentaires
caricaturaux pour ne pas dire populiste
et démagogique et notre débat c'est pas
tout à fait écarté de tels propos
les études de l'incerme et de
l'Observatoire européen des drogues et
des toxicomanies établissent le bénéfice
de ces salles ça a été dit c'est le
choix de moins de contamination le choix
de moins de consommation sauvage sur la
voie publique le choix de moins de
nuisance pour les riverins le choix de
moins de dépenses en matière de santé et
de moins d'exclusion et parce que la
pédagogie c'est la répétition il s'agit
d'une expérimentation qui s'adresse à
des personnes usagées marginalisées
l'enjeu est de sécurité sanitaire de
sécurité publique ces salles seront
ouvertes en concertation avec les
responsables locaux et je le dis je veux
le dire avec beaucoup de cœur notre
haute assemblée je le pense s'honorerait
honorerit le débat politique et ferait
la preuve de son ouverture sur les
réalités de notre société aujourd'hui en
votant cet amendement merci Monsieur
dodini monsieur mou pas en votant
l'amendement de suppression bien sûr
mais vous l'avez compris
euh monsieur mouiller a la parole 2
minutes et demi oui madame la Président
Madame le Ministre oui quelques mots
tout d'abord pour dire que je je
soutiens très fortement la position du
président Milon sur ce positionnement
alors c'est clair que le grand débat
c'est à ce qu'on est pour au contre les
salles de shoot dans dans la lecture
actuelle du texte bien la Commission a
clairement évoqué la notion d'être dans
une démarche de de dans démche médicale
on est bien dans une notion de soins et
je crois que c'est important et cette
nuance est fondamentale parce que
aujourd'hui on on voit bien toutes les
difficultés qu'il a pu avoir à Paris
lorsqu'il y a fallu trouver un lieu
expérimental pour intégrer cette salle
de shoot et a été le vrai débat on a
entendu sur la sécurité publique on
l'entend cette démarche mais lorsque
vous discutez avec les médecins grande
catégorie de médecins et bien le regard
positif se porte uniquement sur la
capacité d'accompagner de pouvoir
dialoguer échanger et pouvoir
éventuellement sortir ce nombre de
personnes de cette difficulté quand vous
avez l'occasion de témoigner ce qui a
étaé le mon cas avec d'ancien toxicomane
la plupart vous dit voilà si on est un
jour on est sorti de cette situation là
c'est parce qu'on a fait la bonne
rencontre et la bonne rencontre à 90 %
du temps ce sont des soignants et donc
l'idée c'est de pouvoir avoir ce lien
encadré entre les personnes qui sont
malheureusement malades de de de de la
toxicomanie et ceux qui ont la capacité
de repérer et de pouvoir les accompagner
pour sortir de cette situation là donc
ma ma position et un certain nombre de
sénateurs ont accompagné c'est de dire
dans l'état actuel non il faut modifier
le texte mais dès lors qu'on adose voir
même qu'on intègre les salles et
peut-être faudra peut-être les renommer
mais mais c'est sales je dirais
d'accompagnement des personnes malades
de la drogue je pense que c'est un
message que nous devons apporter pour
les soignants et pour ceux qui qui ont
besoin finalement d'être sortis de cette
situation merci Monsieur mouier monsieur
Vassel vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente merci alors
je veux pas être sur la même position
que notre collègue monsieur Bouillet qui
vient de plaider en faveur de l'adoption
de cet article moi je me mais plutôt du
côté de ceux qui ont plaidé en faveur de
sa suppression pour quelle raison
d'abord je considère que vouloir
légiférer dans ce domaine est un mauvais
signal pour l'opinion publique et
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens euh c'est
une façon de légaliser la consommation
donc de ces drogues or l'ensemble de
l'arsenal législatif que nous avons en
vigueur et qui s vit depuis plusieurs
années a pour objectif justement
d'éviter et de lutter contre cette
consommation donc on se trouve dans une
situation qui est complètement
contradictoire alors j'entends bien les
arguments qui ont été développés à la
fois par Alain Milon et par Madame le
Ministre qui a étayé son exposé des
motif en faveur de cet article en
donnant quelques références de pays
voisins européens l'Espagne les Pays-Bas
et il est vrai qu'on ne peut pas rester
insensible au fait que des résultats
significatifs semble-il dans cespay
plaide en faveur du maintien de cette
artique ceci étant euh je n'ai pas été
non plus insensible à tout
l'argumentaire développé par notre
collègue Gilbert Barbier même s'il n'a
pas pu aller jusqu'au bout du
développement de son argumentaire mais
qui a fait référence à des experts à des
professionnels et nos collègues
également monsieur
grand également monsieur le mooine qui
ont fait état d'expérience dans d'autres
pays d'Amérique du Nord d'Australie
également de pays européens où la
conclusion faite par les experts un
certain nombre de journalistes qui ont
enquêté sur ce sujet conclu que ces
expérimentations ne sont
pas ne sont pas concluante en terme de
résultat donc si aucune expérimentation
si aucune expérimentation n'avait été
conduite dans d'autres pays je
comprendrais que la France puisse tenter
cette expérimentation pour en mesurer
les résultats procéder à des évaluations
mais de nombreuses expérimentations ont
été conduites pourquoi ne pas tenir
compte de celle-ci et considérer que il
n'est pas probant de mettre en place ce
dispositif sur le territoire national
donc pour toutes pour toutes ces raisons
pour toutes ces raisons je voterai les
amendements de suppression merci madame
procasscia vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais dire au président et au
rapporteur de la commission que je les
suis sur tout ce texte mais sur ce point
sur les salles de shoot je ne les
suivrai pas j'ai bien compris votre
raisonnement mais la concertation avec
les villes je n'y crois pas la
concertation ça sera on vous demande
votre avis on dira non si un maire ou
une ville disent non mais c'est pas pour
autant concertation ne veut pas dire
qu'on est
d'accord et on imposera aux villes des
salles de shoot
éventuellement à proximité des hôpitaux
et la deuxième raison c'est que la
ministre nous a bien dit sur ce sur ce
point comme sur alors sur ce point
peut-être pas aussi clairement mais
qu'elle r elle voulait son texte je
serais
persuadé que adossé à des hôpitaux et
avec l'avis
favorable des mairies cette
expérimentation pourrait avoir lieu je
voterai peut-être ê cet amendement
contre mes convictions mais pour
l'instant dans l'état je suis pas
convaincu et je
suivrai tous ceux qui ont déposé des
amendements de suppression merci Madame
David a la
parole merci madame la Présidente pour
le groupe communistrre républicains et
citoyens nous soutiendrons cet article 9
tel qu'il a été rédigé et nous ne
voterons donc pas les articles de
suppression comme madame la ministre l'a
bien rappelé il s'agit d'une
expérimentation de salle de consommation
à moindre risque nous tenons également à
à souligner que nous saluons la position
responsable des rapporteurs qui sont
convaincus comme nous de l'utilité
sanitaire de T structur notamment suite
à l'audition de professionnels de la
réduction des risques en effet le but
des salles de consommation à moindre
risque est de fournir un accès aux soins
plus rapide aux usagers de drogue les
plus éloignés des parcours de soins et
ainsi les protégés de tourisme risque
d'infection de contamination d'audose et
j'en passe je voudrais peut-être pour
essayer de convaincre nos collègues
rappeler quelques faits et en premier
lieu qu'il y a nécessité à faire évoluer
une loi qui date de
1970 deuxièmement on dénombre dans le
monde une centaine de salles de
consommation et ce dans 10 pays dont h
pays européens madame la ministre en a
cité quelques-uns mais il y a aussi des
salles de consommation au Portugal en
Espagne en Allemagne au Danemarc et il y
en a une en Suisse à Berne et elle
existe depuis
1986 donc la France est bel et bien en
retard en Suisse encore le nombre de
décès par overdose a été divisé par 2 en
20 ans et selon un rapport publié en
2010 par linerme sur les centres
d'injection supervisé les salles de
consommation ont permis de diminuer les
risques liés à la prise de drogue
injectable et de toucher des populations
jusqu'àors exclu en facilitant leur
intégration dans un parcours de soins
autre point dans les pays qui ont mis en
place ces structures on ne constate
pas d'augmentation pardon de
l'utilisation des drogues on ne constate
pas non plus de hausse de la délinquence
comme peuvent le craindre les
détracteurs et au contraire on constate
une baisse des nuisance autour des
structures voilà quelques brefs éléments
qui doivent nous inciter à enfin
autoriser ces expérimentations et madame
la ministre l'a également rappelé
plusieurs villes de tendances politiques
différentes se sont porté volontaires
alors enfin il faut que cette cette
question de santé publique soit prise à
bras le corps merci Madame David
monsieur grand a la parole pour 2
minutes et demi
oui merci Madame la la présidente madame
le ministre monsieur le le le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous moi je je il
y a pas deux sortes de sénateurs ceux
qui ont pas compris qu'il faut soigner
ceux qui ont cette adduction mortelle
hein et puis ceux comme nous parce qu'on
est contre le le le texte qui serient
totalement insensibles l'expérience
personnelle qui est la notre d'élus de
terrain ancien hein nous connaissons
tout ça par cœur et parce que nous le
connaissons au plus profond hein des
mots de la société nous sommes mobilisés
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez dit
parce que je démontrais combien il y
avait des pars d'ombres dans dans votre
texte vous nous m'avez dit que les qu'
aurait pas d'immunité pour ceux qui
viendraient dans les salles de shoot
c'est dans la salle de shoot qu' aurait
l'immunité mais c'est c'est étonnant
cette affirmation pourquoi parce que si
le la personne qui vient dans cette
salle de shoot et bien il faut bien
qu'elle ait la drogue dans la poche et
la drogue dans la poche vous pensez bien
que si elle vient chez elle hein les
policiers vont l'arrêter et donc elle
arrivera pas à la salle de shoot donc
c'est pas compliqué c'est pas compliqué
les policiers savent tous que ceux qui
vont dans la salle de dans la salle de
shoot c'est parce qu'ils ont de la
drogue dans la poche bon donc par
mécaniquement hein il faudra que sur le
parcours hein il y ait pas de policier
et ça vous irez l'expliquer aux forces
de l'ordre moi ce que je ce que je dis
aujourd'hui c'est que les services
d'adctologie il faut les renforcer la
prévention il faut la renforcer
l'éducation à l'école he et dans les
lycées dans les universités il faut la
la la renforcer mais de grâce ne passons
pas ce signal qui je me permets de le
dire et d'abord un signal politique un
signal politique du gouvernement hein
pour faire plaisir au vert comme sur
d'autres sujets et nous n'avons pas et
nous n'avons pas nous à tomber dans ce
panneau parce que pour je m'excuse mais
moi j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir été
élu sénateur de la République hein sur
l'étiquette politique qui est la mienne
pour voter des ouvertures de salle de
chot
merci Madame archambau madame marchambau
vous avez la parole pour 2 minutes et
demi je voulais dire que notre groupe
votera le le le maintien de de l'article
9 et rejoint complètement la position de
la Commission des affaires sociales les
arguments défendus par son président et
la position du gouvernement rapidement
parce qu'il s'agit bien d'un problème de
santé il s'agit de de se préoccuper avec
bienveillance de nos de certains de nos
concitoyens qui sont très loin de nous
qui ont rompu avec toute la vie sociale
sociétale et il s'agit d'autre part
d'une
expérimentation très encadré je n'ai pas
compris du tout qu'on allait l'imposer
aux municipalités c'est les
municipalités volontaires qui peuvent le
faire et c'est une
expérimentation dans ces salles de
consommation à moindre risque alors moi
ce que je voulais dire dire simplement
je voulais répondre notamment à Monsieur
le mooine qui a et je suis d'accord avec
lui il a
dit il faut une stratégie générale de de
de lutte contre la toxicomanie en effet
les la mise en place d'une
expérimentation de salle de consommation
c'est une toute petite partie de
l'ensemble du
dispositif de prévention des
addictologie en direction d'un public
très ciblé et Monsieur Le Moine vous
dites
oui il y a un problème et il faut
trouver des solutions et vous dites il
faut trouver des solutions il faut
trouver des solutions qui permettent
d'entrer en contact avec ces personnes
qui encore une fois sont très loin vont
pas venir prennent pas contact comme ça
facilement entrer en contact avec ces
personnes et il faut mettre en place une
prise en charge médicalisée très
sérieuse c'est exactement ce que
propose c'est ça la mise en place de ces
salles d'expérimentation dont j'ai parlé
donc c'est bien un problème de santé de
de en effet de bienveillance le mot a
été employé envers des concitoyens qui
sont très loin et si le Sénat au-delà de
nos appartenances partidaire les uns et
les autres pouvaient prendre une
position je crois en effet que ce serait
un signal dans ce pays qui est euh sous
pression de discours
populistes dangereux caricaturaux qui
diffuse le poison de de la peur de la
division de la peur de l'autre je pense
que position du Sénat sage
raisonnable ferait du
bien je vous remercie monsieur Richert a
la
parole Richard monsieur Richert a quitté
le Sénat il y a un bon moment madame la
Présidente de prononciation outrancière
non non c'est pas
outrancier madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues moi je
ne voulais pas intervenir sur cet
important
dossier mais je me sens obligé de le
faire
notamment après les interventions de
Monsieur dadini l'intervention de Madame
archambau à l'instant qui une nouvelle
fois parle de posture politique
caricatural je prends les
termes populiste de la part de celles et
ceux qui n'ont pas compris ce message
concernant les salles de shoot moi je
voudrais dire ici que je suis venu sans
arrièrepenser à ce débat j'ai comme les
uns et les autres lu beaucoup sur ça
j'ai été interpellé j'ai reçu des mails
des uns et des autres et j'ai écouté ce
matin très fidèlement ce débat je je
suis venu je le
répète sans savoir quel serait mon sens
du vote et après avoir écouté les
arguments des uns et des autres je je
voudrais dire comme on a et conscience
je ne peux pas voter pour la la position
de la Commission et je le regrette
vivement il me paraît que les
inconvénients de ces salles sont plus
nombreux et supérieurs en importance que
les avantages de ces salles et c'est
trop facile de dire on va faire des
expériences et puis et puis après on
verra et puis seul ceux qui veulent les
organiser peuvent les
organiser vous savez bien que dans le
pays que nous vivons lorsqu'une
expérience est partie elle elle elle
perdure c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et puis après même si
effectivement à la suite de difficultés
de mise en œuvre de cette expérience
d'autres collectivités ne mettent pas en
place de telles salles nul doute que les
anciennes salles perdureront avec
peut-être encore moins de garantie que
ce que l'on a aujourd'hui c'est la
raison pour laquelle et je vous prie de
croire mes chers collègues sans
arrière-penser et parce que j'en ai
assez de ces leçons de morale on les a
eu hier sur la publicité sur le 20in et
on l'a eu sur le paquet neutre et on l'a
encore aujourd'hui je voudrais vous dire
je le répète en mon un et conscience je
prends une position qui est absolument
pas vous l'avez compris politique
puisque je vais à l'encontre de ce que
pense le président respectivement le
rapporteur qui sont de mon bord
politique je ne pourrais pas suivre
cette position de la Commission et je
vote euh les amendements de
suppression monsieur Barbier a la parole
pour 2 minutes et demi monsieur Barbier
je merci madame la Présidente moi je
voudrais simplement dire plusieurs
choses on a fait allusion aux ce qui se
passe à l'étranger euh on peut faire
dire un petit peu tout ce qu'on veut aux
statistiques on a étudié quand même ceci
de manière importante oui non mais vous
contestez je va vous demander qui est-ce
qui est allé voir une salle de shoot à
l'étranger
moi aussi je suis allé à kenf à Genève
j'ai passé une journée et j'ai vu
comment ça se passait bon il faut faut
voir les choses comme elles sont la
deuxième chose c'est là que je suis pas
d'accord avec le président de la
commission c'est que si dans notre pays
on ne faisait rien j'ai l'impression
dans son discours que véritablement ces
gens étaient complètement à l'abandon
c'est quand même faire fi de ce qui se
passe dans les carudes c'est ce qui
c'est faire fit de ce qui se passe dans
les xapas où nous avons des
professionnels qui travaillent sans
et qui vaudrait mieux peut-être pour
consacrer l'argent disponible à
effectuer des maraudes comme le
recommandé monsieur Emmanuelli pour
faire venir ces gens vers des centres
qui existent alors on va adosser ça aux
hôpitaux mais ça existe déjà dans
l'exapa on organise la lutte contre le
le moindre risque d'ailleurs on parle
pas de sans risque on parle de moindre
risque ça veut dire que c'est toujours
une politique qui est celle de la
l'injection d'un produit toxique je
crois qu'il faut véritablement faire
confiance au réseau qui existe dans
notre pays beaucoup d'hôpitaux les CHU
ont des services d'adidictologie qui
sont des services performants alors on
va créer cette ce pseudopode qui va être
adossé à certains hôpitaux et qui vont
fonctionner d'une manière dont ne
contennait pas exactement le
fonctionnement et surtout les résultats
mais on sait ce qui se passe aussi dans
beaucoup de pays qui ont fermé parce que
vous évoquez peut-être Bern je signale
qu'azuric il y a deux salles d'injection
à moindre risque qui ont été fermé
compte tenu des troubles que ça posait à
l'opinion au niveau de la sécurité
générale madame chilinger a la parole
oui je vais pas prendre les 2 minutes 30
madame la Présidente juste pour vous
dire que je soutiens pleinement madame
la ministre ça fait un peu plus de 10
ans que je suis élu donc sénatrice et ça
fait 10 ans qu'on a le débat moi j'ai
travailler 19 19 ans en Suisse baleville
et balcampagne et je connais les
problèmes et je dois féliciter CIT ce
pays qui s'est engagé il y a plus de 30
ans pour justement subvenir à ces
personnes qui sont en difficulté moi je
suis pas pour la politique onit des
trois singes on entend rien on ne voit
rien et on ne fait rien je veux dire
aujourd'hui nous avons la possibilité de
mettre en place une expérimentation une
expérimentation c'est pas une
généralisation ça fait 10 ans qu'on en
parle ça fait 10 ans qu'on fait des
rapports mais c'est ces personnes on les
laisse pleinement dans la rue et et
ailleurs et on s'en occupe pas mais
c'est à nous parlementaires d'aller une
fois dans ce sensl et on a une
proposition moi je pense qu'il est le
moment de voter chacun prendra sa
responsabilité et moi je suis fière que
Madame la Ministre elle s'engage dans ce
sens-là c'est une la politique de santé
et
engageonsnous tu veux maintenant après
non madame Moo vous avez la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues je crois que
beaucoup de d'arguments ont été
développés et que les arguments qui ont
été développés vont tous dans le même
sens c'est-à-dire dans le sens de la
lutte contre le fléo qui la drogue il
n'y a pas ici un seul sénateur qui soit
pour l'usage de la drogue et nous
voulons tous trouver des solutions en ce
qui concerne ce ce fléo mais il ne faut
pas classer euh les sénateurs selon le
vote qui va qui va avoir lieu en les
bons et les mauvais de d'un côté et de
l'autre ce n'est pas ça il faut trouver
la meilleure solution bon si elle
existait si on la connaissait ce serait
facile de l'appliquer mais bon
malheureusement il y a déjà beaucoup de
de de de de processus mis en œuvre et
mon collègue monsieur Barbier vient de
le développer il est vrai que dans les
villes on connaît tous le réseau
villehôpital il y a des déjà beaucoup de
choses qui sont faites malheureusement
bon il y a toujours ceux qui continuent
à se droguer et bon je crois qu'il y en
aura toujours il y aura toujours bon
ceux qui resteront en marge mais les
salles de shoot ne sont peut-être pas ce
que nous souhaitons c'est peut-être on
ne sait pas d'ailleurs ce que ça
pourrait donner donc moi je bon je ne
voterai pas je je voterai la suppression
parce que bon je pense qu'on n pas tous
les T t tous les tout ce qui pourrait
nous permettre de juger que que c'est la
bonne solution il faut continuer à
travailler il faut continuer à s'occuper
de de ce sujet mais bon nous ne savons
pas encore quel est le meilleur la
meilleure solution il faut continuer à
il faut renforcer ce qui existe déjà
voilà ce qu'il me semble merci merci la
parole est à René vandiren
donc on nentend pas René comment si un
maire de roubé qui respecte infiniment
les positions exprimées sur tous les
bancs
je voudrais dire que le courage que
montre la ministre sur cette question
mérite le plus grand respect et va de
paire avec un renforcement un
renforcement du service d'addictologie
de l'hôpital et donc je me sentirai
presque lâche de ne pas dire que
j'apporte mon soutien à la
ministre merci Monsieur mana vous avez
la
parole
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues mon
intervention sera brève et n'utilisera
pas les 2 minutes 30 mais qu'il me soit
permis de faire un témoignage personnel
j'ai effectivement un fils qui est
éducateur spécialisé qui travaille dans
une grande association amiennoise dans
la capitale picarde et qui s'occupe
justement de ces problèm et de ses
drogués et bien moi je peux vous dire
que ce soit les éducateurs spécialisés
que ce soit les adictologues ils
appellent de leur vœux ces salles de
shoot parce qu'ils constatent eux
quotidiennement les dégâts que la drogue
peut faire sur l'espace public dans le
domaine public sans encadrement sans
qu'il y ait de garantie sanitaire ces
salles de shoot au moins permettrait à
travers cette expérimentation en étant
bien sûr encadré en étant adossé à un
hôpital et bien de pouvoir aider ces
personnes qui sont en grande difficulté
et de faire reculer l'usage de la drogue
et c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
salue l'initiative de madame la ministre
je voterai effectivement cet article 9
et bien sûr je ne voterai pas
l'amendement de
suppression merci la parole est à Madame
de roche rapporteur madame la la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues c'est vrai lorsque nous avons
abordé l'examen de ce texte concernant
ces salles de consommation réduite et je
préfère ce terme aux salalles de shoot
qui sont très médiatiques mais qui ont
forcément une connotation caricatural
j'étais très partagé bien que médecin
j'étais très partagé parce que j'étais
sensible en effet à ces arguments qui a
développer Jean-Pierre grandand qu'on
développé d'autres de cette forme
d'incohérence en disant la drogue n'est
pas légale en même temps on dit à des
gens vous allez venir vous piquer à tel
endroit néanmoins nous avons fait
beaucoup d'auditions et et toutes les
personnes que nous avons rencontré qui
vivent au côté de ces personnes parce
que ce sont des personnes qui sont même
pas borderline elles ont complètement
franchi les lignes complètement franchi
les lignes et se dire B si il y a une
solution qui qui est une solution parmi
d'autres bien sûr ça apparî t les
problèmes d' dictologie surtout chez ces
chez ces publics mais en même temps il y
a tout un arsenal à utilisé en matière
de lutte contre la toxicomanie cette
expérimentation elle a fait elle en fait
partie c'est une expérimentation alors
on peut dire ailleurs ça marché ailleurs
ça n'a pas marché je pense que comme
toute expérience celle que l'on fait
soi-même est toujours la meilleure
expérience et et que les statistiques
elles sont elles sont très variables on
fait dire au aux études un peu ce que
l'on veut donc j'ai euh changé un peu ma
position initiale en disant il faut que
l'on donne cette cette possibilité et
quand Catherine procaia nous dit si
j'étais sûr que ça dosé si j'étais sûr
que qu'il y avait une concertation du
mer je le voterai mais si on supprime
l'article on pourra même pas faire voter
les amendements que nous avons déposés
qui sont en effet ceux d'une proximité
d'une proximité avec le avec l'hôpital
et surtout en effet que le ma soit
concerné mais dans une expérimentation
comme ça je ne vois pas comment on
pourra implanter des salles de
consommation avec contre la vie du Mair
d'ailleurs ce sera plus des
expérimentations qui vont se faire dans
des villes où les maires quand ils sont
face à ces populations et face aux
difficultés que vivent ces populations
et que vivent les familles et que vivent
les familles qui sont autour le désarroi
des familles qui voient leurs enfants
parti parce que la vie elle est faite de
belles rencontres mais aussi mauvaises
rencontres et ces enfants ça peut être
les nôtres no petits enfants ou d'autres
ou des membres de notre famille je pense
qu'on doit le leur donner leur chance et
je voterai donc contre les amendements
de
suppression mes chers collègues je vais
mettre au voix les amendements de
suppression qui ont reçu deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement donc qui est pour les
amendements de
suppression
contre
hein ils ne sont pas
adoptés trois nouveaux amendements
identiques et ensuite un sous-amendement
alors le 34 rectifié bis
euh qui le présente Madame je vous en
prie vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente Madame
la ministre les collectivités locales et
leurs élus sont incontestablement de
plus en plus souvent impliqués dans les
questions de santé c'est pourquoi la
décision et les conditions
d'installation de salallle de
consommation à moindre risque doivent
faire l'objet d'une concertation en
amont avec l'ARS la structure porteuse
et le maire de la commune
concernée monsieur le moine vous avez un
sous-amendement à l'amendement que vient
de présenter madame a richot oui tout à
merci madame la Présidente euh
effectivement je propose par le
sous-amendement de faire en sorte que
dans les villes de Paris Lyon et
Marseille ce soit non seulement le maire
de la commune qui qui qui qui qui
émettent cette enfin avec lequel il y
est concertation mais également le maire
d'arrondissement ou de secteur concerné
euh alors vous allez dire mais les
sénateur de Lyonne qu'est-ce qu' VI
faire avec Paris lyon-mseille bon ben il
se trouve que nous sommes sénateur de la
République et par ailleurs j'étais élu à
Paris il fut un temps et j'en retiens de
cette expérience que dans les
arrondissements nous sommes quand même
souvent en première ligne face aux
administrés dès lors que des des
problèmes des des des des sujets un
petit peu compliqués complexes comme
ceux qu'on a voilà qu'on qu'on traite en
ce moment et sur lequel on voit que
voilà il peut y avoir des des des
appréciations divergentes et bien à ce
moment-là c'est le maire
d'arrondissement le maire de secteur ces
élus locaux qui sont bah qui qui sont
spontanément interrogés démarchés et
donc il me semblerait de de bonne
politique de prévoir que la concertation
aille au-delà dans ces trois villes
au-delà du du maire de la commune et
associe ses ses élus de de proximité
voilà merci c'est Monsieur mouiller qui
présente le suivant peut-être le
291 rectifié
quateur bon oui donc on dans le même
esprit donc on est sur une démarche où
on propose qui que le maire de la
commune concernée soit associé à la
réflexion et à la décision d'ouverture
d'un tel espace en tant que premier
magistrat voilà donc là on est bien en
réflexion et
décision merci le 9 le 882 rectifié
n'est pas
soutenu bien je vais demander l'avis de
la commission sur ces
amendements alors cette fois je vous
demande votre avis monsieur Milon c'est
pour les fois où je vous le demande pas
donc là il faut que vous le
donniez nous étion en pleine discussion
madame la Présidente excusez-nous
euh donc pour ce qui est de l' des
amendements
présentés la commission a donné un avis
favorable à tous ceux qui ont été
présentés y compris le sous-amendement
de Monsieur
mouiller quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement écoutez je comprends bien
que cet amendement paraîtêtre un
amendement de de bon sens mais
précisément parce il est de bon sens euh
je veux
dire que pour nous il il va de soi que
les maires sont concertés sont consultés
pardon euh et d'ailleurs le cahier des
charges des
expérimentations prévoira pufin il
prévoit puisquil a déjà été travaillé la
mise en place d'un comité de pilotage
local présidé par le maire de la commune
le directeur général de l'agence
régionale de santé et le représentant de
l'État dans le département le maire
d'arrondissement étant associé à la
concertation pour Paris Lyon Marseille
donc moi je donne un avis défavorable
dans la mesure où c'est répétitif par
rapport à ce qui est prévu mais je
comprends bien la logique de
l'amendement c'est plus le senti donc
disons je donne un avis de sagesse dans
la mesure où ça me paraît redondant par
rapport à ce qui va
exister il me paraît pas utile de le
préciser dans le texte de loi et sagesse
aussi pour le sous-amendement madame la
ministre oui madame la
ministre pardon madame la ministre
sagesse aussi pour le sousamendement
oui très bien donc je vais d'abord
mettre au voie le
sous-amendement de Monsieur leemoine
numéro 1207 qui est
pour c'est des avis favorabl ou
sagesse donc il est adopté je pense
contre oui c'est ça adop adopté donc je
mets au voix maintenant les trois
amendements identiques ainsi
amendés avec avis favorable de la
commission et sagesse du gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient ils
sont
adoptés amendement maintenant 409
rectifié
qu'unquèe monsieur
mouiller oui donc dans dans la logique
de des interventions de tout à l'heure
donc l'idée étant bien entendu de
préciser que ces salles de consommation
serait alors dans un premier temps
adosser mais je pense même que la
lecture devrait aller plus loin jusqu'à
intégrer à d'établissement donc de santé
le principe étant bien d'intégrer cette
démarche dans un acte de médicalisation
et donc de suivi à rajouter également
que un accompagnement sanitaire et
social est également essentiel au sein
de ces
structures
l'avis de la commission favorable du
Gouvernement non un avis
défavorable parce
que les
expérimentations pourront avoir lieu
dans des lieux différents en fonction de
ce qui paraîtra adapté à la situation de
la ville et je peux vous dire que parmi
les projets qui sont actuellement
travaillés il y en a qui ne sont pas
adossés physiquement à un hôpital à la
demande du maire et des associations
locales qui souhaitent organiser
structurer la prise en charge
autrement le ces salles n'ont pas une
vocation hospitalière certaines comme à
Paris d'après ce qui se dessine pourront
être à proximité ou même adossés
intégrés dans les locaux d'un hôpital
mais la supervision ne sera pas
hospitalière la gestion ne sera pas
hospitalière euh et les les il doit y
avoir une porte d'entrée clairement
identifiée comme à part spécifique par
rapport à l'hôpital ce sont des publics
particulierers qui ne doivent pas être
confondus avec les publics qui vont à
l'hôpital pour des choses différent donc
je ne souhaite pas le gouvernement donne
un avis défavorable à ce qui apparaît
comme restrictif par rapport au projet
et amèneraiit certains des projets
actuellement travaillés à ne pas pouvoir
être
retenu donc avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
monsieur Barbier vous avez la parole
oui on voit bien là l'ambigué de du vote
qui a été fait c'est que maintenant une
fois qu'on a adopté cette salle on
dévoile les batteries de Madame la
Ministre c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est la
démarche qu'elle a toujours défendu
d'ailleurs on sait très bien qu'elle ne
veut pas que ça soit adsé un hôpital ce
sont des structures qui seront
indépendantes et je pense monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
sociales que c cet élément vous le
connaissiez alors aujourd'hui dire qu'il
faut que ça soit adossé un
hôpital moi je suis éventuellement
favorable com en repli sur cette
ouverture mais on sait très bien que
c'est pas la beé de la
ministre monsieur Milon vous avez la
parole je je je je trouve un peu fort de
café quand même l'expression de Gibert
Barbier euh mettant en doute ma conna du
sujet je j'ai toujours dit Monsieur
Barbier
clairement que c'était un problème
médical et que ces salles de shoot
devaient être je disais adossé et notre
collègue a dit intégré et je préfère le
terme intégré au terme adossé donc on
fera un sous-amendement d'un commission
pour dire intégré
mais à l'hôpital et d'ailleurs
l'expérience l'expérimentation qui est
en train d'être mise en place sur Paris
se fait bien à partir d'un hôpital donc
n nous nous souhaitons nous clairement à
la Commission et c'est dans le texte de
la commission donc il y a pas de
changement par rapport à à l'évolution
du texte en ce qui nous concerne c'est
bien dans un hôpital intégré un hôpital
avec en plus dans ce qui a été
voté la l'intégration dans la décision
du maire ou du maire ou du maire de de
quartier de manière à ce que les PO
soit intégré à la décision les médecins
intégrés à la surveillance et les
adctologues puissent travailler avec les
les drogués c'est bien dans ce sens que
nous avions fait des propositions et les
membres de la commission avait été bien
informé de ce sujet y
compris sur les bandes de la gauche on
avait bien parlé d'intégration un milieu
hospitalier avec l'accord des élus donc
j'ai pas changé d'avis monsieur bar sur
sujet pas du tout merci Monsieur Le
Moine merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente comme je l'avais précédemment
développé je pense que la logique
d'aider les personnes à sortir de de de
cette dépendance voilà est largement
supérieure à celle de voilà les
entretiens un peu dans dans cette
logique de dépendance et
donc traitement médical quand même et
quelque chose qui qui doit pas être
négligé et j'entendais notre collègue
Philippe Mouillet dans sa présentation
de l'amendement
évoquer l'intégration établissement de
santé et donc quand je vous ai demandé
la parole c'était justement pour
proposer qu'on prenne en compte cette
amélioration sémantique par un
sousamendement mais le président a voilà
par avance répondu en en disant que la
Commission allait le proposer donc voilà
si c'est le cas je naturellement je
voterai le sous-amendement et voilà je
vous remercie il a été voté hein votre
sous-amendement non en fait on parle
d'un d'un autre sous-amendement lié à à
l' à l'amendement 409 que nous discutons
à l'heure actuelle et le débat portait
sur un sous-amendement oral euh voilà
qui vise à remplacer le mot adosser par
le mot intégré ah oui pas encore ou
d'accord j'ai compris madame le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
c'est une réponse à Gilbert Barbier qui
nous dit voilà vous nous avez dit
lorsque vous
avez demandé de ne pas voter la la
suppression de l'article
euh vous avez dit que ce serait avec
avis du maire que ce serait euh adossé
ou intégré à l'hôpital et vous voyez la
ministre n'est pas d'accord donc en gros
vous êtes fait vooir mais non on vote un
texte au Sénat donc la commission des
affaires sociales du Sénat est très
claire elle souhaite en effet que
l'expérimentation se fasse dans des
lieux intégrés aux hôpitaux et àprès ave
du maire c'est ce que nous souhaitons
nous au niveau de notre notamment au
niveau du groupe pour la majeure partie
c'est que le texte qui sort du Sénat
soit celui-ci après l'avenir du texte on
sait bien quel sont l'avenir des textes
au Sénat mais vous n'avez pas le droit
de dire que en proposant en effet de
renforcer le côté médical de
l'expérimentation on est en train de se
faire avoir on vote ici un texte nous on
souhaite avoir un texte et c'est le
texte qui est sorti de la commission qui
est celui-ci ce sont des
expérimentations qui sont fait d'un
cadre médical et en concertation avec
les élus et j'espère que c'est le texte
qui sortira de notre
assemblée merci madame le rapporteur
alors Monsieur Moulier est-ce que vous
accepteriez qu'on modifie le mot dans
votre
amendement oui
donc on rectifie au lieu du mot adosser
un établissement de santé ce sera
intégré on est d'accord très
bien donc il garde il est numéro 409
rectifié sex yes
voilà Monsieur Vassel souhaite faire une
explication de vote
madame la Présidente je voterai le
sous-amendement de notre collègue
monsieur Bouillet mais je voudrais faire
remarquer au rapporteur à Madame de
roche que il y a quand même un petit
yatus dans dans son dans son
intervention parce que je comprends que
la Commission c'était sa volonté que
cette notion d'intégration à
l'hôpital soit dans l'article or si je
lis le texte qui nous sort de la
commission ça n'a pas du tout été rédigé
ainsi il faut attendre un
sous-amendement extérieur ou un
amendement extérieur pour que ce soit
intégré dans le texte donc la commission
n'avait pas pris
l'initiative de d'ajouter cette
précision dans le texte donc c'est
vraiment la séance publique qui va
permettre de le
faire oui nous avons rectifié c'est un
amendement donc rectifié de Monsieur
Moulier ce qui est était plus simple que
de faire un sous-amendement et cetera
mais évidemment il y a madame le
rapporteur qui va vous donner
l'explication que dit en effet dans le
texte qui est sorti de la Commission de
juillet ce n'est pas là mais on a
travaillé toute cette semaine par
rapport aux amendements nous avons
travaillé toute cette semaine sur les et
nous avons clairement défini que le que
les amendements présentés par les
sénateurs du groupe et qui mettrai cette
aurait un avis favorable de la
commission bien donc je vais mettre au
voix cet amendement 409 rectifié sex
avec un avis favorable de la commission
et un avis défavorable du gouvernement
qui est
pour vous avez demandé la parole
monsieur Dodig je vous en prie alors
explication de vote
oui madame la Présidente excusez-moi
j'avais levé la main précédemment m
minist chers collègues j'avais dit tout
à l'heure que le Sénat dans sa globalité
sonorit à ne pas voter les amendements
de suppression c'est ce qui a été fait
je pense que c'est un bon moment dans la
vie de notre haute assemblée sur ce
point précis nous partageons les
arguments qui ont été présentés par
madame la ministre mais il nous
appartient aussi de veiller à ce que le
compromis la globalité de la position
puisse être défendue sur ce sujet
important donc sur l'amendement le
groupe socialiste
s'abstiendra je vous remercie donc je
vous pr mes chers collègues de m'excuser
on encore une explication toi oui
monsieur madame David madame la
Présidente tout comme notre collègue
d'dini je voudrais dire que nous nous
abstiendrons parce qu'en
effet l'amendement
voilà ne va pas tout à fait dans le sens
de ce qui était proposé dans ces salles
de
consommation à risque réduit mais voilà
et adsé nous aurait mieux convenu parce
que adsé ça veut dire qu'il y a le lien
avec l'hôpital il y a la structure il y
a le soutien il y a la coopération mais
intégré c'est vraiment à l'intérieur
d'un hôpital et il me semble que c'est
ça ça va poser quelques problèmes
d'ailleurs dans les hôpitaux parce qu'il
va falloir qu'il trouve un lieu pour
intégrer ce service voilà donc adosser
nous convenait mieux qu'intégrer et dans
l'idée c'était c'est la même chose
puisqu'il y a quand même le lien avec
l'hôpital donc voilà nous nous
abstiendrons sur cet amendement au
groupe communiste bien on peut quand
même on peut quand même exprimer on a 2
minutes 30 mes chers collègues je vous
ferai remarquer que j'ai écouté vos
explications et que je ne les partageis
pas forcément mais je les ai écouté très
bien Madame
archinau même position pour notre groupe
alors je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 409 rectifi sex qui est en
train d'être distribué ce qui vous
verrez qu'il y a le mot intégré à un
établissement de santé avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour cet
amendement qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté deux amendements
identiques monsieur am il est pas
là non mais c'est pas ah si Monsieur
requier il est
défendu madame
Arch madame
arch excusez-moi madame la Présidente
rapidement cet ajout vise à mieux
intégrer les acteurs associatifs de la
promotion de la santé qui ne serait
certes pas soignants ni travailleurs
sociaux mais malgré tout dûement formés
dans la mise en œuvre de
l'expérimentation d'un espace de
consommation à moindre risque s'agit par
là de permettre un accompagnement
renforcé sur les plan sanitair et social
en complémentarité des acteurs médicaux
sociaux et soignants merci avis de la
commission
oui les les deux amendements madame la
Présidente merci sont identiques
et la commission a émis un avis
défavorable car
l'expression ainsi que des acteur de
promotion de la santé est trop large et
ne fait référence à aucun acteur bien if
madame la ministre
oui avis
défavorable merci je vais mettre au voix
ces deux amendement identique 873
rectifiés et 1061 monsieur requier vous
souhaitez finalement prendre la parole
oui je retire parce que le fait qu'on a
intégré ça dans le mil
hospitalier infirme un peu l'amendement
donc il nous reste l'amendement 1061 de
madame archambo qui archembau pardon qui
était identique qui deux avis donc
défavorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstien il
n'est pas adopté je vais donc mettre au
voix l'article
9 monsieur Vassel vous avez la parole
oui madame la Présidente malgré les
amendements qui ont été apportés au
textes qui sont certes souhaitables
parce que ça permettra de limiter quand
même les conséquences qui ont été
dénoncé par Monsieur Barbier tout à
l'heure dans son argument argumentaire
tout à fait bien construit moi je ne
voterai pas l'article 9 pour rester
cohérent avec moi-même ayant voté
l'amendement de suppression tout à
l'heure donc je pense la logique
voudrait qu'on adopte la même position
merci Monsieur Vassel pas d'autre
explication de vote je mets au voix donc
l'article 9 qui est
pour
ça ça pas
large qui est
contre qui
s'abstient l'article 9 est adopté je